Hi!
I'm Ana.
Welcome to 'What to Say!'
Do you know what to say when you talk about other people?
Listen out for useful language for talking about other people.
Then, we'll practise saying the new phrases –
after this.
How's your new project going?
It's going really well.
Great.
Do you work with the digital team?
Yes, I'm helping them with a new website.
So, do you know Anya Patel?
Yes, I do. I just emailed her.
She's lovely, isn't she?
I worked with her in my last job.
Yeah, I like her a lot.
She's very good at her job.
She's an excellent businessperson.
Really?
Yeah, she always gets what she wants.
Oh …
I still need to discuss the contract with her.
I see.
OK …
That's her!
Good luck!
Thanks.
Hello, Anya.
Noelia speaking!
Hello again!
Good luck, Noelia!
So, did you notice the useful phrases used for talking about other people?
Listen to me and then repeat.
Do you work with the digital team?
Do you know Anya Patel?
Yes, I do.
She's lovely, isn't she?
She's very good at her job.
She's an excellent businessperson.
Try and use some of these phrases the next time you talk about other people in English.
Bye for now!